so as he alluded to when he introduced
me and I told him that since he's
introducing me first he's going to set
the stage or anything I want to say
about him but I've known this next
person for 10 years uh and so much so
that I enjoyed working with him so much
that part up of a conference with his
company so I think that speaks a lot I
just want to speak very highly of him
then I'll start joking about him um but
so interestingly one of the reasons I
feel very safe around him is that he can
choke you out with his foot everyone
please welcome Jake
all right so uh today we're going to
talk about organizational in by
ontologies it's really a a boring title
for how to hack your organization with
data because that's really what we're
doing is you know this first off
like what is this fancy word okay uh
inconceivable I think that was what uh
Indigo Montoya kept complaining about
but everybody keeps hearing this word
ontology and everybody has their own
little definition that they're spinning
off on it and really I'm here to tell
you it's actually a very simple thing
that you need to focus on it's just
Concepts and how they interrelate like
we have a concept of a D4 conference we
have a concept of these chairs the
chairs are inside of the embar
collective that's another concept so the
chairs are inside the embar collective
which is associated with this conference
wow you just build an ontology it's that
simple it's dead simple uh and it's
important because it's this conceptual
conceptualization of how we view the
world uh and we can use that to interact
with with data but how do you get these
Concepts you or
organizationally you you're going to
struggle with people to say this word
ontology to them and they're going to be
like what does this mean man like I
don't understand they're going to go to
Wikipedia find out came from Plato and
philosophers but but really you already
have all of these Concepts already
they're written down they're the goals
of your organization they're your
objectives and key results your okrs
they kpis they're the effects the the
mission that you're trying to achieve
those are the concepts what is it are
what are you trying to do you can derive
the concepts from that and here's a
couple examples here uh you know company
acts Implement new customer
Communication System you see the good
commercial example where you like uh Dan
you know previously was talking about
you know strategic competition during
the acquisition process they want to
identify if a company has ties to China
that would be you know some some goals
that they have and then some Concepts we
can derive from those and you know it's
not as like Pat and simple as that you
have to do a little bit of work and be
like okay acquisition process maybe
that's the title The ontology I'm going
to generate I I know it's going to be on
companies I'm going to investigate them
you companies have people people
associated with them they have you know
activities that they do legal activities
Financial activities uh there's there's
features associated with those people
those all turn into an ontology you more
conceptual view of the problems that
you're trying to
solve so you you pull that out and you
you describe it you write it down but
then the data gets a vote right you know
reality gets a vote you may need to
adapt that ontology a little bit to the
data you have or maybe you go through
that that exercise you took your goals
you generated that ontology and you're
like wait I don't have the right data to
solve my problem hey that's a good thing
you have just identified that you need
to go acquire more data you need to
collect more data need to get the data
that actually solves your problem
because you don't have it okay focus on
that
um and then this ontology this
simplistic view of the world is supposed
to be for everybody related to that
problem executive to data engineer to
analyst they can all use it and the way
that they can use it is you or excuse me
in that in that database schema you know
because you can then take what you've
generated and turn that into a database
schema in our case we use you know graph
databases integrated into uh you know a
larger stack but that database schema is
then the single source of Truth for all
of those applications at that
application layer
all right so why would you do this again
you you want to get everybody on the
same page you want to have transparency
towards the goals you're trying to
achieve uh and you also want to kill all
of the the data silos right remember the
uh yesterday Malcolm Hawker was talking
about you know data owners and how
they're going away this is a way to help
them along you know you know if the
entire organization has said this is
what we're doing and the EXA Ives and
the data Engineers the data scientists
they'll have Buy in say yes we're doing
that okay I need all of the advisor
data data owner please give it to me the
organization says that we're doing it I
need all of the finance sheet data why
well I have you know entire organization
instead we're solving this problem so
you can get Buy in and then use that
buyin for some effect and then serve out
that data product you know I'm I'm
little bias towards knowledge grph but
you can serve out whatever that data
product is to those multiple user
categories and uh I'll show you an
example how you can do that with with
our software at service group is the
semantic Knowledge Graph but you don't
have to do it that way you can do it
with other software too okay
so see if I get this no looks like I got
to drag
it
okay
uh
sorry okay so I'm going to be looking
back
so uh this is what the data engineers
and the data scientists want they want
you know python notebook this is where
they're going to live
right
not but
then you know you'll have other people
like analysts who want to have
dashboards and apologies apparently I
signed in a little while ago
uh they're going to want to see
visualizations you know Sand Key and
maps and charts and interconnected dots
they're going to want
that but yeah and but other people are
going to want other things right like
we'll have uh oh it's signed out there
we
go we'll have people who are going to
want to interrogate the data with
natural language you know like uh like
we did on the first day with Tim uh and
I'm sorry it looks like it's zoomed in a
little bit too much so it's hard for me
to to see and type at the same
time and it'll generate a query that you
can't see yeah there we go and then
we'll run it and all of this is just
going to be a back end and my my point
of showing you all this is like this is
this backend tool where you could put
those ontologies you know use that to
create a graph schema and then connect
your other applications too to get
everybody on the same
page with whatever visualization
software that they want to use however
they want to interact with it work on
the API
layer get them down with the actual
problem okay so you start making these
graphs utilizing these ontologies which
should be purpose-built to solve
problems they should be application
driven you're going to need a governance
structure so then that application is
associated with the domain that domain
is associated with some kind of
generalized group you're going to need
you know a a top level ontology some
kind of governance layer uh to manage
all of this you know there's a lot of
good standards out there um ISO 2183 is
the one we use but you know there's
there's other top level ontologies
though if you talk to very Smith he he
hooed them all uh except for his um but
the point is you know this governance
layer is not just a conceptual
governance layer it also relates to your
data and how you're managing your data
so you could have you know something as
uh verose as a ontology Foundry is what
they call it but that could be a meeting
you know where you talk about the
concepts related to your problem and the
effects and the things you're trying to
to achieve and you agree on
them and you have a simplistic view that
then translates over to what you're
doing on the data
layer all right so you're going to sit
around and argue about
Concepts wait do you need lawyers to do
this it's like highly paid people in in
that what they do there's cheaper people
that can argue about Concepts who've
been doing it longer than lawyers
they're
philosophers okay and that's actually
who ontology Engineers are they're
really philosophers the the Barry Smith
the guy who created basic formal
antology he's a professor of philosophy
this is what these people do so engage
with them interact with them they have a
lot of nuance and depth that they can
bring to the problem set but don't be
bogged down by maybe you know a
governance structure try to do something
small you know kind of kind of like what
Dan was saying grow something good apply
some governance to it bring it along uh
and and just let your business goals
Drive the organizational data governance
policy people have to understand that
what the data is doing is associated
with the end goal of the
organization and this is a good
conceptual way to do that and wait this
sounds like I have to do okrs yes you
have to have a strategy you have to have
objectives key results you have to have
something that you're working towards
and then use that to drive the data so
this all sounds great Jake you live in
this realm of you know rainbows and
unicorns leprechauns and pots of gold
it's great why don't we just all adopt
the ontologies
tomorrow well please do but you know you
can do it the wrong way and we've seen
it go wrong a
lot if you design it for just one User
Group say I'm going to build all the
ontologies for all the analysts they're
going to find out all the things it'll
be
great what about the decision makers are
they
involved what about the engineers the
people that actually know the features
of the data are they involved you can
get too hyperfocused on one user group
and you bring another one in and they
don't agree so you know just try to
accommodate everybody in that process
because they can all understand the
goals of the organization and the
concepts related to those goals it's a
Common Language uh also when you build
an ontology as a short halflife you
short life where it's just really
focused on one data set you know it's
not going to be as useful you can't use
it again and again and again um so you
watch it when you're doing that also
when an ontology recreates the wheel
it's it's a bad thing you know there's a
lot of really good uh public work out
there on ontologies a lot of ontology
resources I I know uh defense department
has this uh agent uh project that we
recently got access to you know as part
of the dwig uh a lot of like decades
worth the work by all these ontology
Engineers were we were ecstatic cuz why
do we want to do that you know the
people already put a lot of thought
through it and also the the most
important though when the ontology work
is not focused on
outcomes you need to focus on outcomes
strategy effects the things you're going
to achieve and the concepts related to
those and then you'll have an ontology
that drives the data and drives the
knowledge value it can help accelerate
decision making you know provide you
know consistent valid uh valid entities
uh and and you entities that if another
fancy word but it's just that
conceptualization of maybe that chair in
in in your ontology that chair is an
entity in your ontology um and you can
make that a compliance layer to enable
those domain graphs to be combined and
then
interconnected and really what we're
talking about is the decision
making providing
context that's what you need to enable
people with you know you got to reduce
that cognitive load you the the graphic
that you know maybe some of you can see
here is you know you have raw data
information in meeting context anal and
that leads to decision- making so an an
example that I use all the time when I
talk about this is raw data would be
like three back lit colors that are red
yellow and green information in meaning
is okay that's a that's a traffic light
at the South intersection and the lights
red but the context and the knowledge
that you need to make a decision is that
you're driving at that red light so you
better stop uh and the more we can focus
in that contextual layer the more
success we'll have with our organization
you know and integrating you know value
from our data work uh you know provides
that ideal end State enables that that
context so really that's that's all I
had to say well under time unfortunately
I don't want to keep you guys from
the